merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france jean pierre garnier
quel est selon vous l'objectif
aujourd'hui pour le mouvement des gels
et jaune en premier lieu de démentir
toutes les prévisions plus ou moins
intéressés jeu sur l'essoufflement de ce
mouvement qui reconnaissons le si cela
déplaît beaucoup et sans doute
l'événement le plus important de
l'histoire de france
depuis plusieurs décennies les 68
compris d'affaires un mouvement
populaire une insurrection pacifique
jusqu'à présent et que le gouvernement
essaie de criminaliser par une
répression qui au dessus de tout ce que
l'on a pu constater dans les pays dits
développés soi disant démocratique
jusqu'à bordeaux alléger les jeunes ont
appelé à une manifestation nationale
certains groupes sur facebook ont invité
d'autres mouvements à se joindre au
cortège il ya aujourd'hui la volonté
d'élargir les manifestations et de faire
converger les luttes le thème de la
convergence des luttes et manier depuis
on pourrait dire 3 4 ans déjà
ça a commencé avec la loi ni comme rio
fait la lutte contre la loi une connerie
le gros problème c'est que pour que les
luttes convergent
il faudrait qu'il y ait à seulement des
intérêts communs mais un point de vue
commun sur la manière de résoudre des
problèmes convergent hic
qu'est-ce qui pourrait converger très
souvent dit ça a été mon cas mais il
faudrait une comment dirais-je une
alliance entre les pôles ont et les
bobos comme on dit si bien c'est à dire
et les classes moyennes éduquées qui
habitent les centres-villes et
les classes populaires qui sont de plus
en plus marginalisés on périphérie ce
qu'on appelle la france périphérique
vous pas parler trouver un josé lutte
entre les jeunes de banlieue victime de
la de conditions sociales éprouvante et
de la répression populaire depuis la fin
des années 70 et gilet jaune
je crois que c'est un peut converger les
luttes on peut préciser de quelle île il
s'agit quelles seraient les acteurs de
ces vite
ce qui est certain c'est que la
situation économique et sociale en
france va s'aggraver même sens la
pandémie sa saga vrai de toute façon et
pas seulement en france et que cela va
entraîner sans doute des conséquences
assez dramatique et accueille la vo
conditions la population grâce à la
pandémie
pour lui apprendre à obéir l'a
d'ailleurs engagé d'interdire aux gens
de porter un gilet jaune ou de se
référer au gilet jaune j'ai entendu
monsieur l'allemand autrement dit aux
banques les ont obligés à porter des
paillons des masques et d'autre part on
les interdit où l'on retient dix tentes
et des gilets jaunes c'est la mise en
condition par la peur face aux dangers
de la surrection qui pourrait
s'amplifier aussi bien géographiquement
que socialement alors l'obligation du
port du masque aussi et dans un contexte
de crise sanitaire alors que la france
connaît un rebond de l'épidémie quels
sont aujourd'hui les revendications des
gilet jaune le mouvement en est à sa
deuxième année de mobilisation
comment est-ce qu'il a évolué en termes
de revendication ne peut pas dire qu'il
est fondamentalement évolué jérôme
rodriguez je le rappelais ya deux trois
jours
c'est toujours les mêmes en ce qui
concerne la situation financière
économique
en ce qui concerne la démocratie même si
le rythme est plus bandits comme une
solution démocratique
c'est aussi contre la répression ça
c'est nouveau puisque coq le mouvement
des barris n'y avait pas de répression
les revendications se sont pas
radicaliser les morceaux socialisme
communisme capitalisme même ne sont pas
prononcés par les manifestants autrement
dit ils restent sur leurs positions
et paradoxalement c'est ce qui peut
comment dirais je
les rendre à nouveau très populaire
parce qu' on essaie de conditionner
l'opinion publique pour tous les six on
peut dire est manipulée ont fumé par les
médias détenus par les millionnaires que
l'on connaît pour l'heure faire quoi que
les gilet jaune sont à cours d'arguments
doux et résoudre les cas ils sont dans
la rue n'ont pas changé leur évocation
fondamentalement n'ont pas changé et ça
n'est pas je crois à des intellectuels
ou des commentateurs diplômés de leur
dicter ce qu'il doit faire ce qu'ils
doivent penser et comment ils doivent
agir et merci pour votre regard jean
pierre garnier je rappelle que vous êtes
un sociologue